bon on va commencer merci aux
intervenants de la table ronde
précédente donc un autre sujet tout
aussi important qui va nous intéresser
maintenant qui touche aux industries
culturelles et aux médias leur
transition au numérique
bonjour monsieur le sénateur donc voilà
un mot je suis secrétaire national en
charge de la culture et des médias
nommé en 2015 par nicolas sarkozy dont
je remercie sa conscience un travail qui
nous a permis pendant ces à plus d'une
année avec un groupe très dynamique que
je vois présents aujourd'hui d'amener
beaucoup de propositions des gens du
secteur privé et du secteur public mais
tous professionnels donc merci à eux
d'avoir été présent c'est un vaste vaste
sujet effectivement puisque on a parlé
du théâtre on parlera du patrimoine on
aurait pu parler on va en parler
d'ailleurs de la radio on a parlé de
l'intermittence voilà la culture ça va
aussi de l'édition à la danse de
l'éducation au cinéma à la télévision
c'est très très basse dont on essaiera
d'être modeste dans notre approche c'est
matin en tout cas très très content de
de participer à ses travaux aujourd'hui
donc les axes de travail qui ont un
petit peu motivé notre notre réflexion
était à la fois inspiré forcément du
libéralisme qui est une de nos doctrines
et qui visait à libérer les initiatives
parce que je pense que c'est très
important notamment dans le domaine
culturel et de la création et contre les
embrigadement qu'on voudrait parfois
nous faire subir
et puis bien évidemment le gaullisme qui
a aussi porté cette notion de
participation et de rayonnement notre
pays parce que c'est un actif comme on
dit en français en bon français de notre
de notre pays
voilà donc les axes de travail qui nous
ont quittés sont vraiment la liberté de
créer de s'exprimer j'aurais quand même
une pensée pour toutes les victimes
aussi cette année et l'année dernière
qui sont qui nous ont quittés
qui était visé à travers leur mode
d'expression et de l'amener de
consommation culturelle que ce soit au
bataclan et même sur la liberté
d'expression d'autres d'autres artistes
qui ont été touchés notamment à
l'occasion des attentats de charlie donc
c'est cette liberté de s'exprimer cette
liberté de créer et pour nous
fondamental la défense des droits
également c'est quelque chose qui a
beaucoup animé nos travaux tout à
l'heure une constance on a parlé
florence également c'est un sujet de
longue haleine qui a été véritablement
porter initié par nicolas sarkozy en
2007 avec la création de l'hadopi on en
reparlera tout à l'heure avec les
industries musicales c'est quelque chose
qui nous faut absolument préserver
poursuivre défendre parce que c'est
évidemment j'ai bien aimé cette phrase
tout à l'heure de jean noël tronc sur
les arbres qui n'est évidemment qu'ils
sont très beaux mais qui ne pousse pas
par hasard
il faut défendre les créateurs et les
auteurs trouver les moyens de propager
la culture par tous les moyens et c'est
en sortant de l'entre- soit dont
malheureusement parfois la culture est
un petit peu victime et sortir d'une
vision un peu descendante qui est une
vision et qui devrait s'imposer à la
population faire quelque chose de
beaucoup plus participatif en faisant
participer justement à la fois les
citoyens et contribuables
by the way est évidemment en profitant
des occasions qui nous sont donnés
aujourd'hui que le numérique pour faire
participer le plus grand nombre à ces
sujets culturels dont une des travaux
qui disait un petit peu à l'oxygénation
du du secteur culturel
évidemment on
on est très très attentif en tant que
haut républicain ici à tout ce qui peut
être aussi le l'initiative privée et
tout ce qui a pu être fait porter par
d'anciens ministres comme monsieur
aillagon sur le mécénat qui a permis de
créer des fondations très puissante qui
font aujourd'hui il y en aura bientôt
une nouvelle encore à paris fondation
d'art très très importante qu'il faut
aussi un travail de diffusion de prendre
propagation culturel très important donc
ça évidemment poursuivra sur ce rythme
et ce parti pris aussi de la vision
participative de la culture doit nous
permettre aussi c'est le pari de rendre
plus attentifs les citoyens à la
préservation de notre patrimoine et de
notre registre général de nos oeuvres on
en parlait tout à l'heure
plus on les fera participer plus se
seront puis se sentiront responsable de
cette de cette culture générale voilà
donc on redira aussi évidemment lors de
cette table ronde tout l'intérêt qu'il y
a à défendre et à prendre en compte
l'entreprenariat culturel et nos
industries parce que c'est aussi des
industries la culture les industries
culturelles de notre pays
voilà évidemment un autre principe qui a
guidé nos travaux c'est ça nous étonnera
pas non plus l'évaluation et la
responsabilisation des acteurs culturels
c'est pas parce qu'effectivement on est
dans le domaine public
on ne doit pas être évalués et
évidemment responsabiliser encore ans je
dirais donc le on a parlé effectivement
de l'industrie comme une une valeur
industrielle et économique c'est très
importante pour notre pays ça a été dit
mais pour ce qui n'était peut-être pas
là et c'est toujours bon de le rappeler
c'est plus de 60 milliards d'euros dans
notre pib aujourd'hui c'est 3 2 % de
notre pib donc c'est cette fois le poids
de l'industrie automobile on les oublie
souvent c'est autant que le poids de
l'agriculture et de l'agroalimentaire
donc ces voix là et c'est plus de 670
mille emplois créés dans ce secteur là
on parlait même de plus d'un million
tout à l'heure ça dépend comment on
envisage ce périmètre
et c'est donc deux et demi pour cent de
notre emploi actifs donc voilà pour
introduire cette table ronde deuxième
table ronde de notre matinée culture et
qui va comme je vous le disais plus
porté sur les industries culturelles
peut-être faire un point sur ce jour
d'hui l'audiovisuel on a deux
spécialistes ici que je présenterai tout
à l'heure et qui vont nous parler de
ceux de ce sujet qui est un sujet qui a
suivi beaucoup de bouleversements à la
fois avec la compétition internationale
aujourd'hui dans les programmations mais
aussi la tnt et donc la multiplication
des chaînes
le digital est là la création des gaffes
à ce qu'on appelle les gars fac on
pourrait même appeler les gars femmes
puisqu'il faut rajouter aujourd'hui
microsoft google amazon facebook apple
donc beaucoup de beaucoup de
transformations et donc sur
l'audiovisuel public
sans revenir à la genèse de dos le rtf
et de la création de l'audiovisuel
public
on peut aujourd'hui dire que
l'audiovisuel public c'est dix sept
mille trois cents personnes qui a obtenu
plus de 4 milliards de dotations 2015
dont 3 millions 3 milliards 6 pardon de
ces apc l'ancien redevances plus de 160
millions de dotations publiques
on peut parler d'un système qui
aujourd'hui malheureusement dans le
public est assez fragmenté france
télévisions c'est cinq chaînes comme
vous le savez radio france est cette
chaîne radio on parlera ceux réussis
dont on pourrait parler d' art et de
lina france médias monde avec france 24
rfi et bientôt une chaîne info que nous
a promis donc oui madame ernotte
avec on le voit bien déjà un certain
nombre de difficultés puisque personne
n'est d'accord au sein de l'entreprise
pour le faire et en tout cas la
certitude c'est que ça coûtera forcément
très cher et que cette nouvelle chaîne
info fera de la france le pays où il y
en a le plus voilà on peut parler aussi
d'une érosion de l'audience de france
télévisions on en reparlera tout à
l'heure mais qui en 2002 il faut se
rappeler qu'il y avait principalement
quatre chaînes de télévision qui faisait
80 % de part d'audience
aujourd'hui c'est 50 7% de ses quatre
chaînes et avec une érosion
particulièrement forte pour france
télévisions puisque france 2 c'est moins
38 hier 7 % et france 3 c'est - 41 %
alors que tout le monde l'aurait c'était
seulement si on peut dire - 23 % donc
une moyenne d'âge qui ne cesse
d'augmenter on est à 60 ans aujourd'hui
et ça prend à peu près un an par an
c'était une vraie problématique et des
jeunes actifs et des mots et des jeunes
en fait tout simplement qu'ils désertent
ces médias publics donc on peut parler
aussi une organisation défaillante
tout à l'heure on parlait des charges
qui pèseraient sur le théâtre les
charges fixes par rapport au coût de
création c'est à peu près la même chose
dans la télévision publique puisque 60%
aujourd'hui
des sommes données à l'audiovisuel
public sont des salaires et des charges
de fonctionnement il malheureusement
seulement 40% à la création artistique
alors que en europe c'est partout
ailleurs donc très différent on pourrait
parler c'est très vaste mais des sujets
aussi qui toucha rareté plus de 260
millions d'euros
sans véritable échange avec le système
public mais emmanuel on parlera tout à
l'heure sans doute je voulais dire aussi
un mot on parlera aussi rapidement des
autres industries culturelles qu'il nous
faut défendre j'en parlais tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas que le secteur
public il ya aussi beaucoup de
d'entreprises de particuliers qui se
battent pour défendre la culture
or on parlera de la musique évidemment
qui est en pleine mutation et
heureusement qu'il ya des des champions
nationaux pour défendre détecter
promouvoir les talents sur toutes les
scènes qu'elle soit électronique ou ou
jazz et autres musiques classiques
on parlera aussi des jeux vidéo est un
secteur d'excellence en france et qui
nous permet de créer plus de 20000
emplois directs et indirects
il y avait qu un numéro trois mondial
c'est que be soft dans la salle
également on en dirait un moteur le
secteur de l'animation qui est très très
important et puis on parlera aussi
peut-être soudain 6 parce que c'est un
sujet qui mériterait en soi une table
ronde de la presse et de la situation de
la presse aujourd'hui
donc désolé d'avoir été aussi non je
voulais donc passé la parole tout de
suite a donc eric woerth qui évidemment
vous le connaissez tous est notre
secrétaire général ici à ses jambières
d'accord d'accord sur sur l'audiovisuel
public
donc jean pierre leleux qui est sénateur
des alpes-maritimes ancien maire de
grasse président de la communauté
d'agglo pôle azur provence et qui est
surtout aujourd'hui ici pour nous parler
d'un autre
deux rapports d'information qu'il a
écrit en septembre 2015 très intéressant
et qui parle d'un nouveau modèle de
financement de l'audiovisuel public et
de la création à terme de france médias
qui pourrait voir le jour en 2001 sous
le sénateur carle et à vous merci
beaucoup je vais essayer d'être
synthétique pour résumer ce rapport qui
a été publié au mois d'octobre dernier
qui a fait suite à une bonne année
d'auditions et de travaux pour faire des
propositions
d'abord des constats et des propositions
pour l'avenir de l'audiovisuel public
le constat c'est que l'audiovisuel en
général dans le paysage français
mais l'audiovisuel public en particulier
n'a pas su s'adapter aux bouleversements
de la révolution numérique
on peut le comprendre mais en tout cas
il y a un thème motards que une réforme
vigoureuse est absolument nécessaire
nous sommes passés d'un système d'un
paysage national fermé réguler et en
quelques années à un système
international mondial ouvert et est
dérégulé qu en quelque sorte dans lequel
les oeuvres doivent circuler avec un
modèle qui a évolué extrêmement vite
incluant l'explosion de l'offre de
contenus comprenant également une
délinéarisation de toutes les
les émissions de ces contenus une
multiplicité croissante des supports sur
lesquels on peut recevoir l'image animée
et puis un phénomène qui est en train de
s'accélérer qui la convergence des
métiers
c'est à dire certains professionnels qui
changent de métier qui prennent le
métier de l'autre et c'est comme des
distributeurs qui deviennent producteurs
et diffuseurs également donc cette
révolution n'a pas été suffisamment
suivi par l'audiovisuel en général du
fait forcément d'une réglementation
extrêmement tendue dans notre pays et du
fait
de la difficulté de s'adapter à cette
évolution qui est commandée en fait en
fait par les usages populaires
alors ce constat étant fait des
propositions qui ont été exposées dans
ce rapport les propositions qui sont
faites porte sur deux axes on va dire le
financement de l'audiovisuel public et
deuxième axe sa gouvernance tout en
disant que les deux axes sont inter
connectés c'est à dire que l'independent
fond de l'autre on va essayer d'être
synthétique sur le financement
on identifie bien entendu trois sources
de financements qui sont ceux que l'on
appelait la redevance c'est à dire la c
ap la contribution à l'audiovisuel
public
le deuxième un deuxième source de
financement c'est la publicité est la
troisième source qui pour l'instant est
extrêmement ténu mais qui pourrait comme
cela se passe dans d'autres pays
d'europe
c'est les retours sur investissements
dans la production audiovisuelle sur la
c ap la redevance
nous pensons qu'il ya un risque
d'extinction de cette redevance
d'abord il faudra en assurer la
légitimité parce que le téléspectateur
se pose quand même la question de la
raison pour laquelle ils doivent payer
une redevance alors que simultanément il
y à de la publicité et que au fond le
service public de l'audiovisuel n'est
pas aussi différents que ce que l'on
pense du reste dans le paysage
audiovisuel
donc pour nous la question se pose de
savoir si oui ou non un service public
de l'audiovisuel est utile pour moi
c'est incontestable il faut qu'il y ait
un axe fort de l'audiovisuel public dans
un paysage plus vaste où le
l'audiovisuel privé doit également
s'épanouir aujourd'hui l'audiovisuel
public c'est environ 25 en tout cas pour
la télévision
c'est environ 25% et ça me paraît voilà
ça me paraît bien encore faut-il qu'il
se différencie très très rapidement
quand on le voit en terme d'image en
termes de couleurs du reste dans ce
paysage donc la redevance il faut la
légitime et il faut qu est la limite
comme un impôt local on le paye
volontiers ce qu'ils peuvent quand même
le cas ni pour l'un ni pour l'autre par
un certain nombre d'éléments donc une
redéfinition très claire du rôle de
l'audiovisuel public dans dans le
paysage l'extinction le risque
d'extinction progressive de la redevance
est patent pas tout de suite mais dans
les deux trois années qui viennent du
fait de la multiplicité des supports et
que la redevance n'est aujourd'hui lié
côte téléviseur et que le téléviseur
petit à petit non pas disparaît mais
semé mais quasi disparaît au profit des
autres supports de réception d'image
animé comme les ordinateurs comme les
tablettes comme les iphone qui eux ne
sont pas assujettis en réalité
aujourd'hui à la redorent donc il y a eu
un débat il est toujours il est toujours
présent entre un modèle que l'on va
appeler à l'allemande
ça m'embête toujours de comparer parce
que les comparaisons sont pas toujours
très bonne mais qui serait au fond une
uniformisation par foyer d'une redevance
parce que les statistiques et des études
démontrent que dans chaque foyer il ya
au moins sept écrans si on n'ajoute
l'ordre les ordinateurs les tablettes
les iphone et que au fond le téléviseur
devient presque marginal et que petit à
petit n'ayant plus de déclarations de
possession télévisions meynard de vente
donc soit on paye par écran ce qui a été
dit soit on paie par ménage
en supposant que l'ensemble des ménages
ont au moins un écran de réception
auquel cas il ne faudrait pas ce que
nous souhaitons augmenter la pression
fiscale entre guillemets de la redevance
parce que nous ne voulons pas augmenter
la redevance
la pression est déjà assez grande sur
les ménages mais pour une justice et une
équité fiscale bâtir une assiette
différentes sur l'ensemble des ménages
ce qui pourrait permettre soit
d'accroître les ressources soit de
diminuer le cas échéant le montant de la
redevance
donc ça c'est la première proposition la
deuxième la publicité la publicité alors
là les avis sont partagés
waouh mon avis personnel et je crois
qu'il est partagée au niveau de notre
formation politique c'est de supprimer
complètement la publicité sur le secteur
public de l'audiovisuel
alors évidemment ça fait parler ça fait
manquer ça manque de ressources
les structures demandent évidemment le
maintien de la publicité parce que c'est
une ressource
j'aurais rappelé que la publicité sur
france télévisions c'est moins de 10% du
budget c'est environ 8% et que au fond
on peut très bien imaginer que aux
termes d'économies nécessaires et
possibles au sein de l'audiovisuel
public de la révision de la redevance et
du troisième de la troisième source de
financement dans laquelle je vais que je
vais évoquer dans quelques instants
on peut très bien arriver à supprimer
totalement la publicité peut être
progressivement de manière à ce que au
moins on sache que le financement il
répartit publiquement pendant la
redevance qu'il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
sachant plus que le marché de la
publicité est quand même plutôt en
réduction c'est ainsi et qu'il faut
aussi que le secteur privé puisse avoir
ses financements liés à la publicité
donc ça c'est la deuxième proposition à
terme et puis la troisième qui est en
train d'évoluer beaucoup mais pas assez
c'est de permettre aux chaînes de
télévision de disposer de retour sur
leur investissement dans la production
vous savez que les relais
lois les règlements et les décrets dans
notre pays interdisent ou interdisait
interdisent encore aux chaînes de
consacrer leurs obligations à départ
avoir des parts de coproduction dans les
investissements
tout cela pour évidemment protéger ce
qui est tout à fait compréhensible tout
un réseau de production des indépendante
mais qui est quand même aujourd'hui
extrêmement éclaté et qu' il faut ce que
ce qui est en train de se faire
d'ailleurs on veut revenir dans le débat
augmenter la capacité des chaînes de
télévision d'investir et d'avoir des
retours sur les droits de deux dans la
production audiovisuelle et donc
financièrement avoir une ressource
supplémentaire
voilà pour le financement jeu très
rapidement sur la gouvernance
il y à des pertes d'énergie extrêmement
importante dans l'organisation en silo
telle qu'elle existe actuellement dans
l'audiovisuel public avec l'ensemble des
structures au des structures
audiovisuelles
nous préconisons un rapprochement
progressif comme vous l'avez dit dans un
système qui ne serait pas une fusion qui
serait extrêmement complexe d une
gouvernance commune sur l'ensemble des
opérateurs audiovisuels publics qui
pourrait s'appeler france médias avec un
conseil qui piloterait l'ensemble et
ferrer les répartitions elle plutôt que
l'état de la redevance en son sein dans
chacune des chaînes ce qui permettrait
d'avoir des coopérations transversale
entre les rédactions de travailler
ensemble pour éviter cette espèce de
concurrence et entre les différents
opérateurs qui aujourd'hui n'est pas de
mise et il y a là un gisement
d'économies et d'optimisation du service
public qui nous paraissent
extraordinaires à utiliser le dernier
point c'est l'indépendance de
l'audiovisuel
nous nous croyons à l'indépendance à la
nécessité d'une indépendance et d'une
voix là d'une indépendance d'audiovisuel
public il faudrait la garantir en
déconnectant le pouvoir du ministère de
la culture trop important aujourd'hui
sur l'audiovisuel public ne serait ce
que dans la répartition de la redevance
puisque chaque année là c'est quand même
le ministère qui les distribue et que
nous semblons nous pensons qu'il faut
revoir la composition d'un conseil
d'administration et qu'il lui appartient
avec des professionnels avec une cette
recomposition d'opérer c'est cette
répartition
j'ai été peut-être déjà un petit peu
long il ya tellement d'hommes j'ai
s'était passé à lire le rapport il est
en ligne et en ligne sur le site du
sénat
vraiment est très intéressant et
justement vous avez parlé du modèle delà
de la bbc1 qui est éthique a pu vous
inspirer et qui peut être inspirant
effectivement parce que les chiffres
sont assez éloquents sur 5 milliards de
budget écrit en 1922
aujourd'hui on fait
un énorme travail sans publicité et des
dépenses qui ont été baissés depuis 2003
de plus d'un milliard de livres sterling
donc
transition toute trouvée pour passer la
parole à eric woerth
évidemment secrétaire général les
républicains mais aussi d'anciens
ministres recherche du budget
et du travail et auteur d'un rapport
d'information datée de septembre 2015
sur le financement public de
l'audiovisuel en france merci david et
moi je m'inscris dans la droite ligne de
ce qu'a dit jean pierre on a cosigné une
tribune dans un journal on a fait face
d'abord je dois dire que tout le monde
paie ses impôts et les cafards mais
google etc
on est dans un secteur maintenant
extraordinairement à la fois concentré
et dispersé avec une multitude
d'intervenants beaucoup d'argent se fait
dans le domaine culturel la culture est
une industrie
la culture est une économie la culture
c'est bien plus que cela
la culture est aussi ce qui rend une
souffrance lettres de noblesse et une
une société donc c'est beaucoup de
choses mais enfin il ya quand même des
industriels des entreprises qui sont
d'abord là pour servir leurs
actionnaires doivent évidemment rendre à
la collectivité ce que leur a permis de
gagner c'est pas le cas du tout
aujourd'hui des industries dont on pas
sans arrêt elle paye dans un pot
ailleurs dans des conditions tout à fait
anormal donc il faut que les états
réagissent ils sont en train de le faire
et c'est probablement un combat à mener
maintenant extrêmement rapidement tant
au niveau français qu'au niveau européen
ou et bien sûr à celui de l' ocde il
faut être à armes égales n'y a pas de
raison de ne pas payer d'impôts là ont
produit la valeur ajouté un deuxième
point les groupes audiovisuels au groupe
audiovisuel public français est
aujourd'hui affaiblie ce recherches au
fond ça fait un certain nombre d'années
que c'est le cas je vois sous le
contrôle de renaud donnedieu de vabres
qui en tant que ministre a dû gérer cela
c'est probablement la partie la plus
compliquée à gérer pour un ministre de
la culture et de et c'est bien
l'audiovisuel public et l'audiovisuel
public
aujourd'hui il est trop dispersée et
probablement est en charge d'une
identité si on a un groupe d'audiovisuel
public et si on considère comme
important d'avoir de l'audiovisuel
public alors il faut qu'il y ait une
différenciation forte avec l'ensemble du
reste du du secte et nous pensons qu'il
faut maintenant regroupé les différents
acteurs de l'audiovisuel public
des idées très très anciennes qui n'ont
jamais été mises en oeuvre
il faut pouvoir le faire et créer ce
qu'on appelait une bbc à la française
puisque à des modèles on n'invente
jamais rien il ya un modèle extrêmement
puissant qui fonctionne plutôt bien
en grande bretagne il faut pas augmenter
la redevance pour autant jean pierre l'a
dit d'ailleurs on peut envisager des
supports mais il faut pas augmenter le
poids de la redevance pour une bonne
raison qu'on peut pas avoir un discours
sur la baisse de l'impôt d'un côté et de
l'autre un discours sur l'augmentation
de l'impôt de l'autre et notamment un
impôt extrêmement symbolique donc il
faut pas augmenter le niveau de la
redevance mais il ya des ressources
propres qui peuvent être évidemment
beaucoup développée et tout ce qui
concerne les relations que la production
au fond la caisse la capacité à financer
la production plus de 400 millions
d'euros
en ce qui concerne france télévisions
doit avoir un retour normal sur
investissement pour le pour le groupe ça
veut dire qu'il faut réfléchir avec les
producteurs avec les sociétés de
production avec les sociétés de création
à ce juste retour à cette usine à gaz
française de production dépendantes
indépendante de pourcentage de seuil
il faut vraiment y être née pour y
comprendre quelque chose c'est
extrêmement grave d'ailleurs ça ça veut
dire qu'il ya certains qui probablement
arrivants bénéficier parce qu'ils ont
tout compris et puis tous les autres ils
n'ont pas compris donc il ya un moment
donné au fond c'est le contribuable qui
est perdant donc il faut est évidemment
une grande force de création française
mais c'est ce qu'a permis ce modèle
d'avoir une création indépendante et
d'avoir une création propre à la france
et qui a fait entre la france a conservé
un niveau de production et créativité
très important mais il faut aussi va
être certainement un peu d'ordre qui est
un retour vers vers en tout cas france
france télévisions et ça j'y tiens et
nous y tenons beaucoup
il faut que dans ce groupe audiovisuel
dans cette holding qui piloterait
l'ensemble du secteur de l'audiovisuel
peut-être faire une place un peu à part
pour tout ce qui concerne l'étranger
on parlait de france médias monde les
rédactions doivent être extrêmement
tourner vers l'étranger c'est pas des
journaux français qu'ils soient vont
traduire langue étrangère c'est des
journaux pour d'autres pays qui
s'intéressent pas nécessairement
uniquement à la grève de trains ou des
ordures ménagères à paris encore que
d'ailleurs ici intéresse beaucoup plus
que salée marque beaucoup mais il faut
évidemment qu'il une approche du monde
différente que lorsqu'on est soi-même
français avec derrière les messages et
l'influencé du pays c'est compliqué mais
il faut évidemment garder cette
spécificité
et puis en ce qui concerne les le csa il
faut certainement recentrer le csa sur
ces bases qui sont la régulation de
l'ensemble de l'audiovisuel le respect
des règles enfin la nomination pour
reprendre les sujets les plus polémiques
parce que ces sujets totalement
polémique à chaque fois la nomination
des dirigeants de l'audiovisuel public
ça doit pas être le fait du csa on peut
pas être régulateurs et en même temps
nos mais on voit bien que tout cela
n'est jamais des toujours soumis à un
critique nicolas sarkozy avait fait un
truc c'est qu'il avait dit c'est moi qui
dois je suis président de la république
je suis élu seul élu par l'ensemble des
français je suis le représentant donc
des actionnaires donc jeune homme après
sacré probablement polémique mais enfin
au moins sa clarté d'aider des choses
plutôt que le côté florentin la force
obscure
donc nous devons au contraire rendre de
la transparence est tous là probablement
soit au conseil d'administration soit
soit une commission parlementaire qui
procéderaient à des idées des auditions
tout à fait public il faut que les
choses soient tout à fait transparente
dans ce dans ce domaine et on
s'attachera à faire des propositions là
dessus quand à la publicité
il faut évidemment réduire au fur et à
mesure du temps la publicité il faut
gagner de l'argent sur la production et
vaut gagner de l'argent également sur
des économies de gestion et de
structures et c'est bien sûr possible
donc c'est un défi fondamental et c'est
un défi extrêmement important d'avoir en
face de nous un groupe audiovisuel
public modernisé avec avec la puissance
de feu qui devrait être la sienne et
surtout d'être un canal pour une
diffusion culturelle de qualité
vis-à-vis des français
merci eric effectivement pour continuer
sur ce sujet et moi je suis très
attentif à ce que tu as dit aussi sur la
spécificité des rédactions de notamment
de france 24 pour avoir participé à la
création de cette chaîne je sais à quel
point cette chaîne aussi permet de
valoriser une image dans le dans le
monde avec des avec la hausse a permis
aussi l'éclosion d'énormément de talent
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs sur d'autres
chaînes aujourd'hui je passe la parole à
emmanuel hamelin qui bien évidemment est
très au fait de ces questions il est
secrétaire nationale d'ee république est
en charge de l'audiovisuel
il a été fondateur et président du club
de l'audiovisuel club parlementaire
il est ancien député de lyon est
toujours conseiller municipal de cette
belle ville
ben voilà c'est à toi merci beaucoup
c'est vrai que jean pierre leleux a dit
beaucoup de choses sur lequel je vais
essayer de rebondir parce que son
rapport était effectivement passionnant
et les conclusions bien évidemment
seront celles que nous retiendrons juste
un petit point parce qu'on parle
beaucoup effectivement quand on évoque
l'audiovisuel public on parle beaucoup
le de son financement il est vrai que la
question qui a été posée c'est qu'on va
demander l'année prochaine 137 euros aux
français pour financer un audiovisuel et
la question essentielle qu'il faut se
poser avant d'imaginer quoi que ce soit
par rapport au financement de l'onu elle
sait quel est le lien aujourd'hui qui
existe entre le téléspectateur et son
audiovisuel public
est ce qu'on est capable de répondre à
cette question est ce qu'on est capable
également de répondre à la question
c'est quoi l'audiovisuel public français
quelle est sa spécificité
quelle est son identité à toutes ces
questions là je doute qu'on soit très
nombreux à pouvoir répondre et je pense
que c'est là un élément du problème il
faut donc recréer ce lien particulier
qui existaient qui n'existent enfin
qu'il existe beaucoup moins aujourd'hui
entre les français et leur audiovisuel
public alors ça passe par beaucoup de
choses ça passe d'abord par la
visibilité c'est vrai que les notions de
gouvernance dont parlait jean pierre
lellouche sont importantes c'est à dire
comment doit être constitué
l'audiovisuel public c'est à dire
quel est il en réalité dans
l'audiovisuel public on a évidemment les
cinq chaînes de france télévisions les
sept chaînes de radio france
internationale merci on a radio radio
france monde on à arte mais on a aussi
li na s'est tous à l'audiovisuel public
et donc à tout ça il faut donner une
consistance
le problème de ça c'est que on le voit
aujourd'hui sur la chaîne d'information
qui essaye de mettre en place le
gouvernement
on demande à des rédactions de densité
différente de l'audiovisuel public c'est
à dire financés par les mêmes fonds
publics
on leur demande de travailler ensemble
oulala ça c'est tout à fait impossible
nous on est quand même beaucoup mieux
que les autres et vice versa comment
voulez vous qu'on travaille ensemble on
a notre propre identité notre propre
spécificité
on a l'impression que tous ces gens là
ont oublié qu'ils faisaient partie d'un
ensemble qui s'appelle l'audiovisuel
public français et cette question là est
essentielle et elle se décline sur plein
d'autres éléments en réalité sur
l'ensemble des entités dont je viens de
parler il ya des espèces de palissades
quasiment infranchissable je parlais de
la chaîne d'informations du projet en
tout cas je vous donner un autre exemple
c'est arte arte c'est la chaîne de
l'intelligence arte c'est un budget
quand même d'argent public de 265
millions d'euros
et quand on regarde ça dans son
fonctionnement
on voit par exemple que la partie
allemande de l'arctique est une chaîne
franco-allemande la partie allemande de
arte n'investit quasiment rien dans une
production haddock
en réalité elle utilise la production de
l'audiovisuel public allemand qui sont
ard et zdf pour alimenter la production
de arte ce qui est un système somme
toute assez intelligent et au regard de
ce qui se passe en france on se pose des
questions c'est comment se fait-il par
exemple qu' il n'y ait pas sur arte dès
diffusion de programmes de l'audiovisuel
de france télévisions une question qui
me semble légitime mais qu'on ne se pose
pas
comment se fait-il qu entre france
télévisions et arte y ait pas de projet
de nini denis de coproduction aussi se
poser la question donc on le voit ces
palissades sont infranchissables
il faudra bien à un moment donné qu'on
essaye de les estomper de faire en sorte
que chacun au sein de l'audiovisuel
chaque entité gardant bien évidemment
son identité puisse fonctionner ensemble
en tout cas créer un réseau créé une
mutualisation ou créer des
complémentarités
ça c'est un enjeu qui me semble à mon
avis tout à fait essentiel et si on veut
faire vivre cet enjeu là qui est
justement de d'essayer de regrouper
l'ensemble des entités de l'audiovisuel
public français quoi de mieux que de
l'adapter cet enjeu à la réalité des
évolutions d'aujourd'hui notamment la
réalité numérique
on le voit des plates formes existent
aujourd'hui se développe beaucoup de
plateformes plateformes digitales
étrangères et on parlait tout à l'heure
david hervé boutin dans son introduction
disait que france télévisions avait pris
du retard
il avait en tout cas subi beaucoup plus
que les chaînes privées
le choc qu'a qui a été le choc de
l'audiovisuel dans les 10 15 dernières
années avec l'apparition de nouvelles
chaînes avec la compétition
internationale sur le programme et avec
l'arrivée du numérique
bien évidemment et on le voit france
télévisions sur ses parts d'audience a
beaucoup plus souffert que les chaînes
publiques le chaîne privée pardon donc
il faut se poser la question et cette
question là il ya un des éléments
réponse et qu'on se rend compte par
exemple qu il ya beaucoup moins de
jeunes qui regardent la télévision
publique il ya pourtant une chaîne
dédiée qui et france 4 enfin le voit
c'est un plus pour les enfants et les
enfants regardent de plus en plus leurs
tablettes
donc on se rend compte que les jeunes
mais aussi des actifs regardent de moins
en moins la télévision publique
donc ya peut-être un moyen aussi de
capter ce public là sur une simple
organisation de l'audiovisuel public
français l'idée c'était de regrouper
l'ensemble des entités de l'audiovisuel
public
sur une plateforme qui puisse être
téléchargeable partout sur tous les
supports
qu'on soit en france ou à l'étranger
d'abord ça permettrait de donner un rôle
moteur de l'audiovisuel public sur les
évolutions numériques qui sont en cours
dans notre paysage audiovisuel français
mais ça permettrait aussi avec ce
travail-là de mieux identifier de mieux
reconnaître les spécificités de
l'audiovisuel public qu'il doit qui
doivent être des ducs et de divertir et
d'informer donc cette plateforme
c'est un enjeu extrêmement important si
on veut donner du corps non seulement à
l'organisation mais également à
l'identité et la spécificité de
l'audiovisuel public je voudrais juste
terminer je vous d'avis derby qui prend
un micro ça veut dire que mon temps de
parole est dépassé je voudrais juste
terminer sur les notions de production
qui sont extrêmement importantes en
france on a une particularité c'est que
le lien entre les diffuseurs et les
producteurs est historiquement un lien
difficile et c'est pas parce que le
regard qu'il a peut-être est encore la
salle qui me contredira difficile parce
que on a mis en place un tout un
ensemble de systèmes assez contraignant
pour structurer notre division autour de
l'exception culturelle française ce qui
était plutôt une bonne chose
sauf que cette organisation a un peut
enclencher une sorte de repli sur soi je
pense qu'il faut un peu ouvrir les
choses et un peu débridé les choses
surtout dans cette relation là parce que
quand on voit et dans les propositions
du rapport jean pierre leleux les choses
sont clairement opposés
il faut apporter de la souplesse dans
cette relation là c'est absolument
essentiel
il faut redonner un peu de place aux
diffuseurs qui financent aujourd'hui
près de 80 2% des productions il faut
bien sûr structures et les diffusions
indépendante et faire en sorte qu'elle
puisse continuer à vivre mais il faut
aussi permettre à la production
française de créer des leaders
internationaux
on ne sait pas exporter nos programmes
de fiction ou en tout cas très mal
le premier groupe français de production
indépendant est à la 13e place
européenne donc vous
et qu'on a énormément de travail à faire
au niveau de l'exportation
[Musique]
et c'est cet aspect là de relation
producteurs diffuseurs est un élément
essentiel si on veut développer la
production indépendante et faire en
sorte que la production du vieux
française fonctionne bien avec aussi de
la production dépendante notamment dans
chez les diffuseurs
voilà merci merci à manuel alors
effectivement la transition est toute
faite tu parlais de champion de la
production française il en est d'autres
effectivement dans le domaine de la
musique
ces évolutions numériques les impacts
très fortement on en parlera avec nos
intervenants suivants la musique
aujourd'hui c'est encore cinq centres 43
millions d'euros mais des baisses qui
sont assez conséquentes puisqu'on parle
de 4,7 depuis par rapport à 2014 et une
très forte augmentation donc du chiffre
d'affaires numérique et des supports
numériques et du streaming qui aussi
fonctionne très très bien donc sur la
défense de ses champions nationaux et
les moyens de détecter et promouvoir les
talents de la scène française je
voudrais passer la parole à antoine
baduel qui est président du groupe radio
fg créé en 1992 qui compte aujourd'hui
plus de 30 antennes nationales dont
paris marseille nice mais aussi la
belgique l'allemagne on parlait
d'exportation et d'excellence et de
rayonnement international de nos de nos
talents c'est le câble 350 mille
auditeurs par jour et donc avec une
radio qui a détecté beaucoup de talents
montants que vous pourrez écouter ce
soir sur le champ de mars qui s'appelle
david guetta et qui a été avant tout
reconnu et salué à l'international avant
de l'être
en france qui a toujours un petit peu
dommage c'est le cas d'autres talents
qui que qu'il a découvert comme les daft
punk j'ai beaucoup de rémy hours avant
des victoires avant d'avoir des
victoires de la musique
et plein d'autres voilà tout ce qu'on a
appelé la french touch c'est très
important
c'était une bonne part du rayonnement
constance pourra le dire ils sont 13 où
il fut aussi par la piraterie donc et
aujourd'hui voilà plein de talents
musicaux comme designer qui sont des
niçois qui est cartonne maintenant à
l'international synapse kumstat kir et
voilà sinon je si vous ne connaissez pas
tous ces groupes je vous invite à
regarder sur youtube tous ces groupes
qui sont les groupes français qui ne
chante pas forcément toujours en
français mais qui participe de la
culture française et son rayonnement à
l'international
je passe la parole à antoine bonsoir
bonjour pardon à toutes et à tous merci
à david hervé effectivement juste pour
revenir assez rapidement sur sur
l'histoire de radio fg qui fêtera
l'année prochaine ses 25 ans au départ
en fait quand on a créé ce format l'idée
c'était vraiment de on partait d'une
copie blanche parce que on était sur le
dernier mouvement musical qui a émergé
ces vingt dernières années on a appelé
au départ la techno la house qui était
d'ailleurs très diaboliser à l'époque
pour vraiment faire rayonner le
mouvement des musiques électroniques
l'objectif c'était évidemment qu'on
passait à l'époque de l'ordinateur outil
de travail à l'ordinateur outil de
création moi j'habitais à l'époque entre
la france et l'allemagne
et je voyais un peu le le potentiel est
en même temps le l'ampleur des
difficultés puisque en allemagne c'était
là la musique était devenu le trait
d'union entre deux jeunesses qui fêtait
la réunification il ya eu et c'est
devenu un phénomène de société est
extrêmement symbolique et en france il y
avait eu un déni et diabolisation de ce
mouvement est finalement avec radio fg
qui a été le premier média vraiment à se
consacrer à porter une scène et cette
scène là pour lui donner des couleurs et
surtout un prestige à l'international
l'objectif ça a été justement de de se
fixer l'objectif le plus
le plus élevé et le plus ambitieux c'est
est de vraiment faire des champions
nationaux pour les faire rayonner alors
comme l'a dit david hervé il ya une une
une brochette comment dirais-je
d'artistes très très significative
en tous les cas effectivement le fait
que david guetta aujourd'hui c'est un
hasard mais c'est très symbolique soit
la tête d'affiche de l'événement qui
donne le coup d'envoi de la coupe
d'europe c'est très important
néanmoins ce qu'il faut voir c'est
qu'aujourd'hui cette scène elle permet à
la france de rayonner à l'international
c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire que
les artistes que nous portons et que
nous représentons aujourd'hui à
l'international font pratiquement 60 à
70 % de leurs ventes de leur chiffre
d'affaires de leurs cachets de leur
diffusion en radio
coombs dont on parlait tout à l'heure à
19 ans il vient d'aix en provence
beaucoup d'artistes aujourd'hui viennent
des territoires c'est pas forcément des
parisiens qui viennent de paris centre
ça ça a été la première génération de la
french touch c'est vrai mais aujourd'hui
pour reprendre très rapidement les
quatre cinq artistes dont on a parlé n'y
en a pas un seul qui soit parisien les
synapses on vienne deviennent de nantes
fait des résilles havner viennent de
nice cook vient d'aix en provence et
j'en passe et des meilleurs et ce sont
en plus des artistes qui font la fierté
des salles de musiques actuelles qui les
ont repérés en région des bd eux quand
ce sont encore des étudiants qui les ont
accompagnés et de la jeunesse qui se
sent tout à coup fier que sa ville soit
cité et rayonne au delà de la france à
l'international
je prendrai l'exemple de koons cette
artiste qui à 19 ans de cette semaine on
l'a on l'a détecté au mois de janvier on
a mis tous temple à la radio vraiment
tout un système en place de repérage des
artistes aussi pour promouvoir parfois
des artistes qui mettent leurs morceaux
en ligne sur internet mais
malheureusement aujourd'hui ça ne suffit
pas internet c'est bien pour mettre en
ligne césar ses morceaux mais les
algorithmes mis en place par les fameux
gafa les google les spotify et et tout
cela de toutes façons favorise de
manière exponentielle les artistes et
plus puissants et écrase de manière
extrêmement brutal les artistes les plus
émergents d'ailleurs je tiens à préciser
que ça a même changé la manière de
programmer des radios avant les radios
on les écoutait aussi pour découvrir la
musique
aujourd'hui les fm je dirais
traditionnel et nous justement on a
décidé de de relever la tête et de ne
pas justement admettre ce fatalisme
aujourd'hui on écoute la radio pour
entendre la musique qu'on aime bien et
puis le rôle de la découverte de
finalement la prise de risque étant trop
importantes les audiences ayant été
aussi la mine et parjure
demant les spotify et toutes ses
plateformes de téléchargement pour vous
situer en ile de france
le média radio il ya 15 ans c'était 90 %
de la population
le mois dernier ses 73 % c'est-à-dire il
ya pratiquement 10 7 % en ile-de-france
à présente pratiquement 2 millions de
personnes et chez les jeunes c'est c'est
beaucoup plus important qui ont
abandonné ce média donc l'idée avec
radio fg c'est de relever la tête de à
la fois être de porter les couleurs des
artistes dont des territoires travailler
main dans la main avec les smac pour
promouvoir justement les artistes à
l'échelon international et aussi
d'ailleurs en réciproque
il faut voir que beaucoup d'artistes
allemands notamment belges italiens
australiens américains s'appuie sur
notre savoir faire puisqu'on est
aujourd'hui la seule radio à avoir cette
philosophie de découverte et de
promotion des talents s'appuie sur nous
justement pour ce faire découvrir et
connaître quand il n'ya pas de radio
dans leur territoire ou leurs pays pour
les faire découvrir
en allemagne notamment les robin fuel
cell et félix yen ont démarré en france
et par notre biais on investit
énormément
on a deux personnes à plein temps qui
sont en permanence là pour faire alors
c'est pas un mot très quotas mais ça
résume bien ce qu'on fait en fait du
sourcing
c'est à dire qu'on va chercher les
morceaux qui sont sur internet des
talents pour les promouvoir et leur
donner un écho on a évidemment par
rapport à cela des artistes qui
s'expriment peut-être pas forcément
toujours en français loin s'en faut mais
il porte les couleurs de la france à
l'international
alors on pourra se poser la question
comment nous nous sommes comment nous
sommes nous accommoder de la loi des
quotas d'oeuvre d'expression francophone
les fameux quotas francophones sur radio
fg puisque le répertoire était
inexistant et on avait une loi qui avait
été malheureusement écrite avant l'essor
des musiques électroniques dont qui
finalement c'était pour être en
conformité avec les impératifs de
bruxelles avait finalement dit ben
finalement on
seront côte à les artistes qui chantent
en français et alors que cette loi avait
été fait pour promouvoir les catalogues
locaux je le rappelle au départ et
finalement s'est dit mais on est aussi
les ambassadeurs de la france avec radio
fg pourquoi ne ferions nous pas
connaître avec les la part les 35% de
quotas qui nous sont imposés des
artistes qui sont des producteurs
géniaux qui ont besoin de se faire
connaître
pourquoi de leur part ne pas leur faire
revisiter le grand répertoire français
d'edith piaf à serge gainsbourg de 2
alain souchon en passant par barbara et
de leur faire réinterpréter remixé re
remettra finalement aux couleurs d'une
musique qu'on défend cette ce catalogue
ce répertoire qui est méconnu de la
jeunesse alors du coup finalement on a
fait un format aujourd'hui qui n'a
aucune espèce de d'interdits de tabou je
dirais artistiquement parlant
on fait cohabiter de la grande chanson
française remix et je vous invite à
écouter le dimanche matin vous serez
très étonné c'est très agréable à
écouter avec des artistes électro
je tiens à préciser un chiffre qui est
quand même très significatif il est
tombé hier soir au l'électro la musique
électronique en l'espace de quinze ans
aujourd'hui ça pèse 6,9 milliards de
dollars en revenus en chiffre d'affaires
mondial
le chiffre est tombé est tombée hier et
je pense que c'est suffisamment
éloquents et parce que depuis paris avec
une petite radio qui représente 350
mille auditeurs et 30 fréquent c'est à
dire peu donné la fréquence 98 de bien
sûr c'est à dire deux fois moins de
fréquences que le move 20 fois moins de
budget que le move mais deux fois plus
d'audience
eh bien en attendant on est là pour
porter les couleurs de la france
travailler main dans la main avec les
festivals les régions les territoires
les salles de musiques actuelles et
donner un écho international à des
artistes qui parfois ont 18 20 25 ans
était le cas il ya 20 ans avec les daft
punk c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui et
c'est une très très belle aventure j'ai
pas que ça durera encore au moins 25 ans
merci antoine
la bravo effectivement parler de
champions nationaux de la détection de
la promotion de talents on parlera
peut-être aussi d'un projet qui avait
été proposé par nicolas sarkozy de la
création d'un centre national de la
musique pour justement permettre une
nouvelle économie à l'émergence de ces
talents ce sera sans doute dans nos dans
nos recommandations que président de
présentera tout à l'heure et je passe la
parole
un autre acteur de la radio notamment
numériques
emmanuel jaillir qui est le président de
goom radio qui a cette particularité
d'avoir de faire aujourd'hui des
services aussi sur mesure pour les
entreprises travaillent avec allociné
coca sncf et plein d'autres marques
et c'est l'ancien directeur de la
communication du groupe nrj group bien
connu jusqu'à cannes et notre ami david
lisnard et là des nrj music awards
voilà c'est aussi toute cette scène
qu'il faut défendre et promouvoir banal
bonjour merci d'avoir invité
moi je voudrais en fait réagir sur le
fond du sujet vous avez introduit tout à
l'heure qui est sur l'audiovisuel public
je pense en fait en essayant de lier la
première partie la précédente et celle
ci avec vous avez en fait devant vous un
formidable ressorts économiques
j'entends des 4 milliards investis dans
l'audiovisuel public chaque année ça
veut dire dans les cinq prochaines
années ces 20 milliards moi je
m'interroge par contre sur le fait que
dans ce projet que j'ai lu j'ai
l'impression qu'on est encore au 20e
siècle est en fête avec ses 20 milliards
vous avez probablement la possibilité de
créer de nouveaux projets de faire en
sorte que l'audiovisuel se réinvente
comme les américains ont su imaginer
développer accompagner l'essor et la
création de de l'internet et qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui
l'enjeu n'est plus dans les canaux de
diffusion aujourd'hui pas un enfant
presque depuis dix ans en france qui est
pas accès à tous les programmes
existants en france et à l'international
dans le monde s'est pas non plus du coup
un enjeu de régulation je crois pas en
tout cas que ce soit là les priorités
mais avec 20 milliards il ya en revanche
probablement la possibilité d'appuyer
des projets dans la durée
mais pour ça il faut faire des choix
c'est difficile de s'occuper tout mais
si on reste dans le modèle existant que
ce soit pour la radio et la télévision
moi je ne suis pas certain que dans les
cinq prochaines années ce soit le duo
visuel public de garantir la diffusion
de roland garros ou de questions pour un
champion je suis pas sûr que les
français aient besoin de payer une
redevance pour s'assurer de la pérennité
de l'image vidéo de ces événements de
ces manifestations
en revanche je suis convaincu comme en
toi de le développer de capacité qu'ont
les français a créé et que ce soit de
l'image du son de la musique de l'art
contemporain le gouvernement à mon avis
celui d'aujourd'hui d'hier et ceux de
demain fortiori ont une énorme
responsabilité à faire ces choix là et
essayer de mesurer les résultats qu'on
peut obtenir vous parlais tout à l'heure
de d'éducation je pense que la dernière
chose qu'ils se soient passées grâce à
un gouvernement dans l'univers de la
radio
bah c'est finalement l'émergence des
radios libres en 81 depuis pas grand
chose sous le gouvernement je crois
qu'elle vous avez participé il ya eu la
volonté mais qui finalement était une
demie volonté d'essayer de d'inventer de
la radio numérique qui a été du coup une
dépense dingue pour aujourd'hui un
résultat on sait même pas s'il est
enterrée ou pas je pense qu'il est temps
de faire des choix en fait les français
aujourd'hui ils vous font confiance ils
sont pas capables même de s'engager dans
ces grands sujets c'est à l'image de la
conquête de l'espace de ces grands
projets industriels il faut comprendre
que la culture les médias la
communication
c'est un véritable enjeu de business de
création d'emplois et de développement
de notre image de notre patrimoine à
l'international mais pour ça il faut un
projet vraiment ambitieux et je pense
que c'est pas tant de c'est de
comprendre et de décrire tout ce qui
marche plus il marchait pas ou qui
marchait moins bien avant mais c'est de
se dire comment avec ces 20 milliards
finalement on peut inventer la
communication avec les français pour les
français demain et je pensais ça c'est
un sujet passionnant qui met un espoir
de dingue parce que pour le coup là
dessus il n'y a pas de problème de
moyens je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
beaucoup d'industries qui
et 20 milliards sous les yeux pour
inventer créer merci à mes noël je suis
juste pour préciser bien évidemment il y
aura d'autres tables rondes sur le
numérique 1 c'est un des sujets qu'on a
abordé dans le cadre de la culture mais
c'est pas lui le principal sujet mais
c'est vrai que c'est un le numérique
impacte très fortement la culture quant
au volet programmatique évidemment nous
laissons à nicolas sarkozy le soin de
vous annoncer tout c'est tout si tous
ces points de dirt propositions mais ils
sont nombreux et la prise en charge du
numérique de notre programme est
évidemment très importante et je crois
qu'on a on est là aussi pour en parler
je passe maintenant la parole à une
autre personnalité du domaine de la
musique qui est guillaume leblanc qui
est directeur général du syndicat
national de l'édition phonographique
créé en 1922
donc tu es né un tout petit peu après je
crois et donc et c'est pour ça que
justement c'est quelque chose qui est
toujours d'actualité
défendu par des personnes dynamiques
ses membres représentent aujourd'hui 80%
du chiffre d'affaires du marché du
disque à la fois les fabricants les
producteurs les distributeurs et
guillaume va nous parler effectivement
telle évolution de ceux de ce marché et
de ce qu'on peut tirer aujourd'hui de dd
des accords qui ont été passés avec à la
fois les acteurs et les hauteurs de
musique et toutes les plateformes et les
en termes de revenus de droit tout ce
qui est le basculement de cette nouvelle
économie avec une augmentation du
streaming de 45%
bonjour à toutes et à tous merci pour
votre invitation je vais essayer d'être
synthétique dynamique comme tu disais
j'espère et puis positif parce qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe dans la
musique certains nous qualifierons de
survivants moi je préfère dire des je
préfère parler du terme de pionnier la
transition numérique c'est le thème de
cette table ronde
on est en plein dedans on a est en plein
dedans on est en train d'en sortir
puisque pour reprendre un terme à la
mode
nous avons été dans les premiers dans la
musique à se faire hubert ise bien avant
tout le monde on s'est bien fait hub et
reese et on sait bien on est bien passé
par la machine à laver
on a perdu en france les producteurs
musique donc les maisons de disques que
je représente qu on appelle les majors
monsieur secondes
producteur indépendant ce qui est
investi sur les artistes ont perdu 70 %
de leur chiffre d'affaires
à l'époque un quotidien en 2003
libération ne peut pas le citer dix ans
mais regardez une industrie qui n'a pas
su s'adapter alors que c'est vrai ça a
été compliqué ça a été dur et beaucoup
de pleurs ce plan sociaux dans les
maisons de disques beaucoup de deux
petites structures qui ont disparu on a
perdu beaucoup d'emplois beaucoup
d'artistes qui sont faits l'homme
malheureusement comme on dit fait rendre
leur contrat mais malgré tout si on fait
le bilan et si on prend un peu de recul
je ne pense pas que nous soyons
industrie qui n'a pas su s'adapter au
contraire puisque nous sommes toujours
là il ya toujours des producteurs il ya
toujours des auteurs compositeurs
toujours des interprètes toujours des
producteurs spectacle vous pouvez
toujours aller voir de la musique en
spectacle
mieux la musique est toujours la
première pratiques culturelles des
français et je dirais grâce à internet
puisque je vais y arriver on va
embrasser on a embrassé la révolution
numérique
il n'a jamais été aussi facile d'écouter
toute la musique que vous souhaitez
légalement puisque on a su faire aussi
notre évolution concernant l'offre
légale alors on a fait le pari
d'embrasser plutôt que de subir cette
révolution numérique
alors ça a été compliqué comme je disais
mais y ait eu plusieurs phases dans
cette révolution révolution numérique ce
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui en france vous
avez à peu près plus du tiers et on va
arriver à 55 ans dans les prochaines
années
le tiers des revenus du marché de la
musique en france vient du numérique
plusieurs phases d'abord ça a été pire
ratage le fléau du piratage que toutes
les industries culturelles ont connu et
continue de connaître même dans la
musique là dessus ça existe toujours
mais on a su apporter une première
réponse qui s'appelle le téléchargement
légal je fais la même chose j'ai acheté
un cd dans une fnac mais je peux faire
la même chose grâce à un acteur qui
s'appelle itunes et j'achète un type sur
mon iphone sur sur internet c'est légal
et sa rémunère la création et puis à
quelque chose qui est en train de se
produire maintenant peut-être que vous
connaissez plus ou moins tous le
mécanisme n'a pas le streaming le
streaming c'est quoi c'est un nouveau
rapport à la musique de la même manière
qu'ils vous payer un abonnement pour
louer une auto lib où il faut un vélib
pour les parisiens et bal à vous payer
10 euros par mois 1
bonnement et vous avez accès à toute la
musique que vous le souhaitez de manière
légale c'est super ça s'appelle viseur
ça s'appelle spotify c'est apple musique
je vous encourage puisque c'est là
l'avenir de la musique enregistrée
alors juste un chiffre qui est assez
marquant le streaming l'année dernière
en france 18 milliards de titres ont été
écoutées en france où les plateformes de
musique
je vous rassure tout de suite on n'a
jamais voulu 18 milliards d'albums je
pense que ça s'est jamais fait de lui
pardonner
alors comment elle a réussi à s'en
sortir sans être très rapide les faut
bien reconnaître que la filière musicale
a principalement porté ses efforts elle
serre un peu débrouiller tout seul on a
bien évidemment on a pu s'appuyer sur
quelques dispositifs on n'a pas la
chance dans la musique d'avoir un fonds
soutient ou un navire amiral comme son
personnel du cinéma mais on a su
justement avec quelques dispositifs
comme les crédits d'impôt qui nous ont
bien aidés à se sortir
et puis aussi est une réponse du
politique la réponse du politique pour
la musique mais pour les industries
culturelles
ça a été cette prise de conscience qu'il
fallait stopper l'hémorragie du piratage
et ça a été un moment
le parti-pris d'apporter une réponse
courageuse et politique face au piratage
parce que vous souvenez il ya encore
quelques années c'était le mythe de la
gratuité la musique c'est super sur
internet c'est super d'avoir
gratuitement
donc pour être très concret on est en
train d'y à un moment historique puisque
pour la première fois depuis 20 ans
cette industrie retrouve la croissance
3% de croissance l'année dernière et
tous les signaux sont au vert au sont au
vert une offre de musique pléthorique 35
mio titre sur internet un nouvel usage
vous parlez du streaming qui maintenant
et c'est très facile d'accéder à la
musique légalement c'est très simple
vous pouvez toujours aller dans les fnac
existe parce que tu vois ça n'empêche
pas vous pouvez faire les deux mais en
tout cas c'est très facile et d'autre
part l'abonnement donc on est en train
de trouver le modèle économique
justement qui nous redonnent des
couleurs et qui nous offre un potentiel
de croissance fantastique 45% croissance
à venir c'était super donc faut être
fier de ce qu'on est en train de faire
est faux soyons conscients de la place
de la france on est au centre et les
artistes france à ce rendez vous c'est
des revenus c'est du patrimoine qu'on
rencontre m'en souviens c'était emploi
comme disait jean noël tronc qui sont
menées au cal is able et puis comme
lisez aussi antoine c'est la capacité
croque 11
six actuellement à s'exporter les
artistes français on parle beaucoup du
cinéma français à l'étranger mais
regardez les artistes français quelles
que soient les joueurs quels que soient
les esthétiques s'exporte de plus en
plus peut-être juste pour terminer le
message que je voudrais envoyer nous
c'est aidez-nous politique à nous à nous
accompagner il ya trois ans jeu qui me
paraît très important pour accompagner
justement l'industrie rôle dans cette
mutation numérique pour conclu pour
conclure c'est d'une part exposé la
production locale ça passe à la fois au
niveau national parce que si on produit
il faut gagner débouchés donc exploser
ça passe par la préservation mécanisme
quand les quotas radio mais aussi par un
soutien à l'export nous aider à créer
davantage de valeur c'est tout le débat
sur le financement la création les
nouveaux acteurs qui doivent participer
au financement de la création
et puis dernièrement il faut jamais
l'oublier l'enjeu de ce été signé par
constance monsieur le ministre à
l'époque aussi avait porté le fer nous
aider à continuer à protéger la création
puisque le piratage reste une
concurrence déloyale
merci guillaume c'est très intéressant
en conclusion on peut quand même dire
que on a des champions des champions
nationaux des industries culturelles
nationales qu'il faut défendre dans la
musique et je salue aussi la présence de
10 heures dans la salle mais également
d'autres d'autres acteurs et qu'il nous
faut défendre
on a également le numérique qui nous un
pacte qui doit être et qui peut être une
chance donc il faut qu'on s'en saisisse
effectivement on aurait pu parler de
plein d'autres sujets le sujet de la
presse aussi aidé par mi-temps les
hommes dans les industries très
importante on on a pu déplorer l'année
dernière il ya la semaine dernière une
censure est intolérable
la part du syndicat national du livre
sur la presse c'est un secteur aussi qui
est extrêmement fragile et qu'il le
faudra défendre par des moyens tout
petit peu plus moderne que ce mise en
oeuvre actuellement
voilà enfin le sujet a été vraiment très
très vaste merci d'y avoir participé
merci à nos intervenants
merci à vous
qui est public je passe la parole à
david lee cela avec les délégués en
charge cette question culturelle au sein
de notre parti
maire de cannes je vais pas citer toutes
ces casquettes parce qu'il en a beaucoup
et en même temps c'est très nécessaire à
cannes voilà